let's talk inflation first which i think
is the backdrop for the entire
investment world right now uh the fed
seems to be in control they say they're
going to destroy demand inflation
numbers today 9.1 percent
what is your read as to how to think
about the actual inflation people are
experiencing do you believe the 9.1
percent number or do you think there's a
different way to think about it
i think uh you know inflation is a
vector it's not just one static number
to say this is the inflation rate and i
think it's pretty well documented that
inflation in the areas that matter most
whether you're talking about
prices at the pump food prices the
things that are affecting real everyday
people are dramatically higher than the
9.1 percent but even if you go with the
broken metrics of 9.1 percent we're
talking about the highest inflation in
40 years this is dramatic and if you
look at inflation in other countries
it's considerably worse so globally
we've got a massive problem and nobody
is immune to it
obviously it hit it hits you know people
living paycheck to paycheck the hardest
because they don't own assets that
inflate you know with this inflation um
yeah it's a really vicious thing
everybody's in the same boat
many investors including myself uh kept
talking about bitcoin as an inflation
hedge i think now there's kind of a
nuanced view of that which is well maybe
it's not an inflation hedge in the sense
of inflation goes up and bitcoin goes up
uh to combat that but maybe it's
actually a hedge on the loose monetary
policy so if the fed says they're going
to tighten bitcoin has come down because
people anticipate risk assets to come
down how do you think about whether it's
an inflation hedge or it's a loose
monetary policy i've read some stuff on
that as well and you know the
correlation to the monetary policies
pretty strong and so right now that's
looking like a pretty viable perspective
that said i think that
bitcoin ultimately is an inflation hedge
and that what we're dealing with are
some unique circumstances where
um obviously there's very
thin float in bitcoin from a trading
volume point of view relative to other
assets so it's not manipulated in a
negative way but when you get things
like we have now where there's a
correlation to equities with bitcoin
which i think will ultimately break
because bitcoin is not in equity um but
right now it is heavily correlated and
that correlation is being enforced by
big macro hedge funds who are using
bitcoin to hedge their equity exposure
particularly to
nasdaq and big tech equity so if a big
macro hedge fund has a billion dollars
of big tech exposure and they want to
hedge that because the correlation you
know with bitcoin to tech is kind of
four to one like almost a four beta so
if you had a billion dollars of exposure
you could short 250 million dollars of
bitcoin and be equally hedged so if
stocks go down one percent bitcoin you
know is gonna go down four percent and
vice versa so i think that's reinforcing
this correlation which is kind of
hurting us right now that'll ultimately
break and i also think we get that kind
of technology adoption volatility
i think back to amazon you know ever
since amazon was a public company it has
lost 80 percent of its market cap uh six
times and one time more than 90 percent
so this is kind of expected and it's
hard to be an inflation hedge when you
have that degree of volatility but
ultimately as the asset matures i think
it's going to prove to be an inflation
hitch when you think of the fed and
they're kind of talk track right now
obviously they are talking about
destroying demand uh which i always
remind folks just me they're going to
punish you until you stop buying things
um and we have seen risk assets go down
because people are selling them because
they're listening to the fed but
inflation's still at 9.1 percent and
it's actually accelerating
what are they going to have to do like
can the fed actually get inflation under
control or
no matter what they do it's not going to
come down and so maybe they're going to
have to pivot before inflation actually
comes down
i don't think they're going to have to
pivot before inflation comes down i
think that the fed can be pretty
effective by raising rates it has a
pretty dramatic effect
maybe the most obvious place to see it
is in housing we're already seeing
more housing deals break that are in
contract than we've seen in a really
long time
and just to follow that through one step
it's
as interest rates go up and those
mortgage rates that were two and a half
three and a half percent are now six
percent mortgage rate people are
breaking those deals
prices of houses are being revised
downward um so i think we're starting to
see that and we're going to see it
across the board even more um demand is
going to decrease and i think there's
signs that it already is yeah when you
look at core inflation versus kind of
cpi inflation that includes energy and
food uh is there a reason to look at
core inflation like i know the fed likes
to point at it because it's going down
right now so that's their signal of
saying oh look inflation is going to get
under control how do you look at those
two numbers and do you put more weight
on either one of them no i just think of
i try to think of it across the entire
spectrum of assets and services and
there's what numbers say on reports docs
news reports etc and there's what every
individual feels and the truth of the
matter is i think most people only care
what their personal exposure to
inflation is how is this affecting me
and everyone goes to restaurants
everyone drives a car not everyone sends
it to those prices there are people with
ton of money who are like i don't give a
[ __ ] if the entree is 50 or 75 at the
restaurant i eat but there are a lot of
people who do care about all those
things but those people even the really
affluent people they do care about
whether or not their purchasing power uh
is impacting their ability to purchase a
house you know and all of a sudden even
that wealthy person is thinking of
buying you know this 15 million dollar
house and is going to put you know 13
million of that you know in debt on
mortgage they care that that interest
rate is six percent and not three
percent and so if it impacts everyone i
just look at it through my personal
vantage point to try to assess what the
real impact is and it's dramatic i mean
i i feel it